er macht immer diese dämlichen schild
hängt jetzt auch zornig oder gome kommen
könnte
ich schwöre hoch und heilig ich habe
gestern aufgenommen und dann arbeitet
meist hinein kann man nicht arbeiten und
kommission irgendwas falsch kann ich
nicht theoretisch 100 blöcke von der
stadt entfernt diese mal den titel
hinsetzen
da kannst du wir haben diese gesellen
die schreiben schilder ja wenn ich denke
diese gewählt werden auch im theater
clown vermutung ist entweder eine von
euch alter nein du bist das
hundertprozentig zur 1
oder es ist eine art wenn du was die
ungespitzt also unsichtbar machen kann
könnte das sein
ich denke ich oder wir haben ja gar kein
plugin drauf was das ermöglichen würde
ein jahr ist wegen eigentlich gar keiner
drauf das ist ja mal in minecraft also
zusammen mit gitarrist jan ich keinen
bock drauf
ja also sehr so jetzt soll man alle
leute aus silber wood liest kann man
keine diamanten machen wenn man die
verbrennt was machen diese kalte winter
herrscht
zusammengeschlossen bei der aktion von
denen wegen der regel los lasst uns
ihnen falsche infos geben
ich bin ja nie war für diese regel gilt
willst du wissen wer diese schilder
macht wirklich okay wenn das nicht dass
ich mal meinen aufnahmen bin das nicht
und heute selbst wenn das schild jetzt
gerade gemacht worden ist
das ist ja schon länger glaube ich sind
geschrieben ja punkt renner punkt macht
immer diese dämlichen schilder hängt
jetzt auch zornig oder kommen könnte
ich schwöre hoch ein heiliges an da ich
habe gestern aufgenommen und dann doch
ich bin echt nicht ich hab doch nicht
schnitt tun als regierung voll wenn ich
auf dem willen wird jetzt fünf dieser
ganzen schweiz schüler ab egal wer bei
mir wurde auch übertrieben avant zehn
schilder mit dem gleichen inhalt keine
atomkraft gedacht hab ich vielleicht ist
irgend so ein zuschauer das irgendwie
eingehackt
wenn sie ein zuschauer einmal alles
kaputt ich glaube das kann ich gut sein
ist einfach ein netter zuschauer ein
dummer zuschauer ist was du jetzt net
oder grombein
in einer das netz meiner welt um ist so
ein richtiger den weinkeller nimmt
formen an jetzt schon der zugang dazu
fertig jetzt müssen wir jetzt in kästen
alle runter hauen
das war noch eine arbeit hätten einfach
zu machen
ja wer ist einfach chainsaw glaube das
ist eine frage die welt nicht mehr und
in abgebaut und nichts bekommen
das können wir auch gleich mal bauen hat
haben hier
keystone aber es ist doch eben zuschauer
oder nicht er will zu tun haben
ich glaube hier sind zuschauer ist es
dort zu mit du willst auch kohle haben
ich möchte auch redstone haben jetzt hab
ich auch in telara gefallen gerade mit
all meinen sachen zum glück haben wir
zum aussehen der hände das schlichtweg
ist ein jetpack so kompliziert zu machen
ich brauche dringend 1 sonst bin ich ein
herz hat ein halbes herz glück drei
spieltage bleiben
abgebrannt die rolle hat gebrannt sind
sicher ja habe ich hab ja ich hab ne
chainsaw den schweizer strassen so sehr
gebrannt der freizeit können ja jetzt
auch nicht entladen finde ich viel mehr
so auf erfindung und so sind als bei bei
ratings ist jetzt auch nicht sehr viel
schneller wenn meine bäume auch so leer
haben wie base park darf dann kam jetzt
aber das jetzt ist hier muss drin sein
oder die man am nächsten aber schneller
das hat eine größere fläche auch wird
auch sein trainer der reds
er ist das silber ich habe jetzt
philippsen silber aber ist welcher taste
kann man noch mal was kraft ist
automatisch als zu verteilen mit kohle
irgendwie sowas oder rechts links
gedrückt mit ich glaube ich
ach so richtig und shift ok mckinsey zu
spät
anni hat hingeben ja aber ich habe schon
mit bands kommentar ich ganz abbauen und
dann war es ein perfekter da müsstest du
was von mir nehmen einfach acht personen
verbraucht so viel tim petry laut moment
wofür braucht eigentlich so viel zu
wenig so ich brauchte 444 für die
generatoren
ich kann nur direkten generator gehen
ich hab jetzt sind ich brauche aber zeit
generator ja ich kann ohne zu erklären
was mit strato
ich habe 15 generatoren nein doch habe
ich weitergemacht weil es zu wenig
höhere kosten zu wir haben fehler
gemacht ja ja aber dennoch shift
gedrückt und am 15
am anfang war ihm nachfolgen eine war
viel zu viel klatsch wir gehen da kommt
metro ich hab nur noch acht aber ich
kann trotzdem paar abgeben
acht generatoren merken ich brauche ja
dann sachen einfach ja also ich geb dir
dann sechs oder sogar zwei bier selber
noch da niemand dafür brauche ich aber
will ich auch eine menge item haben
wieso hast du geboren bist mein
kommentar bitte kurz wie sodass ich fand
ihn bekommen aber das mit der dummen das
wird es kann gut sein das passt doch
passt doch zu viel theorie
eigentlich will das echt mal ernsthaft
ins auge der regel alle in folge ja
definitiv
definitiv nicht
leute das geht vorbei dir fir eisenerz
an ärzten und 2 mb mir nicht die geht
krass ab jahr sind back vom serverseitig
ich hab ihn einsam so ein scheiß wir
darauf konnte ich viel spaß mit
atomkraft glaube ich hole mein
grundstück jetzt von und mit der change
mit der pink poms ja ich glaube dass
noch im kopf
ich brauche also meine ganze energie
auszunutzen mann
ich habe mir für energie und ich nutze
noch gar nicht so richtig ist voll nicht
gemacht ihr mehr maschinen europa geht
ja das habe ich schon oder last beim
major soft du immer laufen mit dem
schalter teurer als kerstin descher das
bringt darin immer laufen das bringen ja
immer auf hitze 100 ich sag euch wert
getroffen irgendwie ist bei mir immer
auf 800 manuell besitzt und bla bla bla
bla bla bla es ist aber schön wärs ja
ich weiß bestimmt ja auch noch nur habe
ich es bisher noch gar keine verwendung
dafür so michael controlling geist hier
drauf immer ganz klar auf müsse auf
jeden fall meine fragen auf wir machen
das wir gehen der sache draus genau hat
das neue irgendwie hab ich gerade meine
sache man immer weg plötzlich ja das war
bei mir auch so ich baue auf einmal den
solarpanel ab und kriechen generator
das kann sein muss aber da ist ja aber
ich wollte ich jetzt auch noch mal so
sagen die dummheit richtig ja kann man
verpassen
das turnier noch falsch da ist mir
vollkommen waynes
jetzt wäre ich fick dich einfach
implementiert klar so zum spaß
leidenschaft mensch lebt gerade wirklich
unwetters gehört das unsichtbar nicht
funktioniert beim abbauen glaube ich
kacke
oder jemand mich getraut sollte ich in
dieser aufnahme neuer für alle zwei
jahre alles möglich halte ach ich muss
die change zur auflage für alles was sie
tun
die bringt gar nichts
ich musste aufladen abstrom ich verkaufe
strom kein standing die physischen
verkaufen weil ich genug strom habe aber
sie es verkaufen ist es in nrw just
unter strom da ich ja aber ich glaube
ich dadurch habe ich flieg nein ich
werde ich dir habe ich werde ihnen nicht
verrenken sich gut an hat sich gut an
ich wollte nur ein bisschen
die ganze kisten so zur ächtung einige
richtung machen aber dafür brauche ich
ganz viel kohle weil ich möchte mir
direkt dieser art gibt die man aus
kohlestaub oder kabel platz macht die
aber jetpacks legt den brust- oder das
heißt da kann man nichts aber in die
hosen kann ich mir doch machen was ist
eigentlich gar nicht bewusst weil den
posten nicht mehr
naja aber die hose brauche ich ja nie
getroffen
die hose weißer hose nein ich mache mich
an die aus elektronik links dies folgt
viel schöner uns nicht schlecht ein
diamant sieht gute ja die gute natürlich
vielleicht es gibt ein teenager und
theorie ich habe meditiert u2 oder so
das loch nicht mehr komisch
die macht noch mal panik findet das doch
nicht ausgerückt
noch ist ein satz wie macht man doch ist
so winzig klein ich find's nicht auf der
suche nach dem noch die macht man
wahnsinn leute quasi ja dadurch noch
gefunden und rein darf jeder darf mal so
und so bei uns ist ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz viel logistik
das hatte ich manchmal gebrauchen jetzt
nicht mehr viel
endlich kann ich den abbau ich bin so
dankbar
ich glaube ich danke gott glaube ich für
diese aktion sternchen
in dieser folge werden keine christen
ernsthaft ich bin's nicht brauchst jetzt
noch nicht mehr nicht mehr
ja genau das zu date zum verschenken
wo kriege ich so geil wie krieg ich
sogar lichter her die auch so habt und
so meinem kanal zaubern wir abgebaut
oder von sparkle
verzaubern man kann sich von bommel
holen beschreibt informiere mich nochmal
genau was in meinen keller schlafen
überhaupt nicht er bekommt noch gar
keine energiewende wenn es dunkel ist
doch mal so leicht lässt sich trotzdem
auf von crazy crazy